Und der Song, bitte komponiert einfach ein fucking Ende. Bitte komponiert einfach ein fucking Ende. Bitte komponiert einfach ein fucking Ende. Bitte komponiert einfach ein fucking Ende. Bitte komponiert einfach ein fucking Ende. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Wir sind eine Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO. Leicht verwirrt hier heute bei mir im Studio im Studio, Stefan. Ich weiß nicht, warum du schon sprichst, weil das ist ja noch gar nicht vorbei, es liegt. Und jetzt fängt es wieder an. Ich versuche den in den Fade rein zu bringen, aber das sind die Aufgaben eines DJs, ne? Also das ist die Aufgabe, die man hat, man muss mit Fades arbeiten, rein, raus und Stefan fadet uns gerade in den Podcast rein, ist das nicht toll, das Mikrofon glüht schon, es qualmt. Es glüht, es qualmt, es ist an, der Dieselmotor läuft. Ganz normal, wenn Stefan Tietze am Mic ist. Und Florian ist auch am Mic. Spittet die Rhyme, spittet hier rein. Und wir haben inzwischen einfach nur noch Musikgags. Muss man auch mal sagen, dass wir so eine Community haben, die jetzt so Meta-Musikgags macht. Leute, die neu einsteigen, sind gänzlich verwirrt. Lieben Grüße übrigens an die nächste Welle, die jetzt gekommen ist, durch vielleicht soziale Medien, wir wissen es nicht. Aber es ist egal, wenn ihr jetzt verwirrt seid, ihr kommt schon rein. Da wurde dann so wirklich so Gags im Reddit stehen, sagt die Quinte zur Septime, sei mal nicht so dominant. Und man schreibt ha ha ha, har har har har, einfach nur, wenn man... Man schreibt ha ha ha, aber eigentlich schreibt man bbb, weil b ist ja das H im Sinne. Das war für euch, liebe Nerds, Musiknerds da draußen. Und natürlich auch für Nils, der uns diesen kleinen Dosenöffner des Podcasts an die Hand gereicht hat. Vielen, vielen Dank für diesen kleinen, ich weiß es musikalisch nicht einzuordnen, gebe ich schambehaft zu. Es ist eine Overtüre. Eine gaghafte Overtüre. Ja, der Dosenöffner, er macht auf. Voll, er macht's auf. Nicht so schlecht. Brauchst du häufiger mal Dosenöffner? Ich musste letztens einen Dosenöffner kaufen, weil ich dachte, in meiner Naivität, dachte ich, man würde mir alle Probleme aus der Hand nehmen. Dachte ich eigentlich. Und dass auf jeder Dose ein eingebauter Dosenöffner ist. Ja, das habe ich auch gedacht. Aber manche arroganten, du kommst nicht an mich ran, Dosen sagen, nee, ich habe nicht diesen Hebel. Warum? Ja, ja. Es gibt keinen Grund. Du denkst, du bist was Besseres? Du bist eine Konservendose, okay? Also ich will nicht sagen, dass du komplett wertlos bist, aber du bist, was Nahrungsmittel angeht, schon wirklich ganz unten, okay? Und du musst deinen Platz auch kennen, du musst deinen Platz kennen. Ja, aber ich muss mich, Sir, Sir, Sir, Sir. Ja, bitte, sprich. Aber ich muss mich doch abheben von Spezies oder Cola-Dosen. Ich bin eine, in mir sind wunderbare eingelegte Tomaten. Du bist ganz unten. Ich bin nicht ganz unten. Du bist ganz unten. Und nur wer realisiert, dass er ganz unten ist, kann eines Tages auch wieder ganz nach oben gehen. Du könntest ein Tetra-Pak sein. Ganz oben ist Tetra-Pak. Du kannst eine Mehrwegflasche sein. Diese Skala ist so kacke und dumm und was ist ganz oben? Quetscheis? Quetschis? Ganz oben ist die Waffel. Die Eiswaffel. Eiswaffel, oh mein Gott. Das ist das beste Konserveninstrument. Es liegt nicht an mir. Es liegt an Ihnen und Ihrer beschissenen Skala, okay? Sie sind gefeuert. Ich bin eine Dose, Sie können mich nicht feuern. Ich mach dich jetzt auf.
Aber ich musste tatsächlich dann einzelnen
Dosenöffner kaufen, was unangenehm war.
Und da hat mich die Kassiererin
sogar um ein Foto gebeten.
Wieso einzeln, wieso es unangenehm,
einzelne Dosenöffner zu kaufen?
Weil es so offensichtlich ist, dass du keinen
Dosenöffner zu Hause hast.
Dass du gerade in Sandalen mit Klopapier
an der Sohle losgegangen bist, weil du Hunger hast auf deinen widerlichen Ravioli-Einter. Und entweder hast du es verknibbelt, entweder hast du dich verknibbelt oder du bist einfach mit 32 Jahren so am Leben vorbeigerauscht, dass du keinen Dosenöffner hast. Aber ich finde es auch lustig, weil neulich in meinem Rewe des Vertrauens sind die Kassen kaputt, die selbst Checkout-Kassen. Und ich hab mich, ich hab ganz vergessen, warum ich Einkaufen mal so gehasst habe, nämlich diese verurteilenden Blicke vorne am Kassenband und die Langsamkeit. Generell mit Menschen zu interagieren, am Checkout-Prozess beim Einkaufen immer ein bisschen nervig. Dann hab ich's wieder, dann waren die aus, alle blinkten rot, ich dachte mir schon, das gibt's doch jetzt nicht. Ich leg meinen ganzen Einkauf auf das Band und vor mir der Mann guckt dann so rüber, sieht den Einkauf und guckt dann mich an. Und dann weißt du, dass dein Einkauf sozial nicht so akzeptiert ist. Wenn du rüber guckst und guckst und denkst, normaler Einkauf, interessiert dich ja nicht, wer dahinter steht. Aber er hat meinen Einkauf gesehen und sich dann komplett umgedreht. Also er hat so viel, der Einkauf hat gesagt, wait, es ist wie wenn du im Straßenverkehr eine blöde Situation hast mit jemandem, der vor dir fährt oder sowas, die die Vorfahrt nimmt und dann fahre ich vorbei und gucke mir die Person an. Machst du das nicht? Ich gucke mir immer die Person an, aber ich denke, wer hat diesen Piece of Shit Move gemacht? Weil ich will auch nicht voreingenommen sein, weil jeder hat Klischees in sich, rassistischer, sexistischer Natur, ist einfach so. Ja. Man kämpft dagegen an, aber man kann es zum Teil nicht ablegen, solange man es reflektiert und weiß und damit umgehen kann, ist der in Ordnung. Genau. Und deswegen denke ich mir, was für ein Arschlochautofahrer? Kein Urteil. Ich weiß da drin sitzt was für eine Arschlochfahrerin eigentlich, ich fahr dran, alles in Ordnung und einfach, du musst ja um Rassismus und Sexismus zu bekämpfen musst du dir das einfach durch Empirie ersetzen durch einfach zu, ich guck einfach nach und jetzt mal, wir sind ja unter uns wozu sind deine bisherigen empirischen Studien gekommen? Das möchte ich nicht sagen weil ich auch. Nein, meine empirischen Studien sind tatsächlich dazu gekommen und das ist auch eine Art von Diskriminierung. Alt fährt schlecht. Sorry. Das Ergebnis meiner empirischen Umfrage war. Aber wie belastbar ist es? Ich würde auch behaupten, empirische Studien sind ja schon so ab tausend belastbar. Nicht? Sagt man das nicht so ungefähr? Pi mal Daumen tausend. Ich glaube, es ist bei der Bundestagsunfrage so gut tausend. Okay, aber dann denke ich mir so, ich habe ja mehr Leute mir nach dem Kack-Move vor mir danach angeguckt als tausend. Das heißt, meine empirische Studie, in mir dürfte ja gar kein Sexismus oder whatever mehr herrschen, weil ich ja schon empirische Erfahrungswerte habe. Und based darauf kann ich mir jetzt wieder ein Urteil bilden. Ist das nicht empirisch belegt? Oder meinst du selektive Wahrnehmung? Und jetzt ist die Frage, es ist schwer, ob man da wirklich neutral sein kann, aber ich habe schon das Gefühl, also, und deswegen mag ich das auch so ganz gerne und habe auch Bock, alt zu werden, weil alte Leute einfach mit so einem, mir ist alles scheißegal, fahren. Die sind nicht mal asozial im Sinne von, ah, Sinne von ich schneide ihn jetzt weg, ich gehöre davor, sondern denen ist einfach alles egal. Da wird nicht geblinkt, nichts, da wird einfach nirgendwo geguckt, Fahrspur einfach gewechselt. Ist natürlich jetzt auch ein bisschen verallgemeinernd, aber es macht mir Spaß daran zu denken, dass ich eines Tages auch mal so bin, dass mir alles egal ist. Ja, das freut mich eigentlich auch schon drauf. Und man ist ja auch nicht sauer. Also bei mir wird so ein bisschen die Wut dann so gelindert, wenn ich jemanden sehe, die sehr alt ist, fährt, einen Scheiss macht einen Kackmove und dann guckt man rein und ist schon so, der Mittelfinger ist schon in Triggerposition, aber man sieht es und dann denkt, ja, okay. Hilfe mal bei einer Sache, weil ich habe... Bei einer Sache soll ich dir helfen. Eine Sache. Alles andere ist fertig.
Alles andere ist durch. Wir sind quasi durch. Wir sind durch, wir können auch, können heute mal früher Schluss machen, wir sind eigentlich durch. Ich brauche nur eine Sache. Stefan kann mir bei einer Sache noch helfen. Und zwar habe ich das Gefühl, ein Handzeichen zu benutzen, von dem ich denke, dass jeder versteht, was gemeint ist. Okay. Und manchmal bin ich mir aber dessen nicht so sicher. Und ich führe dir dieses Handzeichen jetzt vor. Kann ich, können wir kurz auf die gedachten Null beide ein Handzeichen machen, was wir, weil ich mache ein Handzeichen gerade viel zu häufig. Okay. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, ob das das Ähnliche ist. Okay, also, es hat was mit Autofahren zu tun, nur für den Kontext. Mach erst nur ein Handzeichen. Und das Handzeichenzeichen ist das hier. Ah, okay, du meinst, laber nicht, ist missverständlich. Und ich, also, mit der flachen Hand, der Mittelfinger trifft den Daumen, so wie Pac-Man, Pac-Man, so ein bisschen. So, was bedeutet das? So, ich glaube, du möchtest damit auch sagen, blinken. Ja, gut, zum Glück. Aber was du, nee, nee, nee, ich bin schon weiter. Aber gut, dass Sie zumindest in der Nähe sind.
Nee, nee, ich habe ... I've been through that.
Ich dachte mir nämlich auch, das schau mal, das ist aber das international verständliche,
zumindest EU-weit verständliche Zeichen für Labern nicht, Labern nicht, Labersnur. Ja, ja, stimmt schon auch.
Und Blinken ist das Zeichen.
Du spreizst alle Finger weg.
Oh, die Spreizung, als würde man die Hand weg, also eine nasse Hand sozusagen weg sprengen. Nee, das ist was ganz anderes. Das wirkt wie eine italienische Geste, die man nicht übersetzen darf. Aber das, also die Sonne sozusagen, also du, genau, die Finger spreizen. Das ist für dich eher Blinken. Das ist Blinken. Aber jetzt hast du eine riesige Verwirrung in die Welt gebracht, weil jetzt gibt es plötzlich zwei Gesten für blinken und jetzt weiß ich nicht, was ich machen soll. Jetzt kann man natürlich so wie dieses Musiker-Ding beide gleichzeitig machen und schauen, ob man zinkriegt. Und der Kreisverkehr, und mach uns nichts vor, diese Geste passiert immer im Kreisverkehr, weil da ist es halt nervig, wenn vor dir keiner blinkt, der eigentlich rausfährt. Genau, und vor allem, ich bin natürlich mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs, und Fahrrad, ich weiss nicht, ob du weißt, ein Fahrrad lebt vom Momentum. Beim Fahrrad ist es extrem wichtig, dass du die Geschwindigkeit aus einer Kurve mitnimmst in die nächste. Und da kann es absolut katastrophal sein, wenn du auf einen Kreisverkehr zufährst und du bremsen musst, weil der, der gerade im Kreisverkehr ist, blinkt nicht, du weißt nicht raus, du bremst, er fährt raus, du hättest nicht bremsen müssen und jetzt musst du nochmal komplett
Gas geben, jetzt nochmal mit deinem neuen
Tetra-Pack-Traubensaft hinten auf dem,
dann musst du runterschalten.
Und dann du, Drama-Queen natürlich, dann immer die grossen Gesten.
Und im ersten Moment, der Lenker
wird auch so verrissen, kurz.
Gott, ey,
du im Strassenbeger, du musst,
ich hasse mich selbst.
Und vor allem, ich denke mir immer so, was ist, wenn die Person einfach gar nicht checkt, was gemeint ist. Es gibt ja Leute, die einfach sagen, ja blink, mein Gott, halt, mei, halt nicht immer. Aber kannst du nicht, am Fahrrad kannst du ja was sagen, gerade Sommer, alle an die Fenster offen. Am Autofahrer, ja, was soll ich da sagen, schön so auf den Mutterrauben klopfen, so auf den Mutterrauben klopfen und sagen sagen, während er an mir vorbeifährt mit 40 kmh, ich mit, sagen wir mal, guten 17 kmh, dann mit einer Gesamtgeschwindigkeit von 57 kmh. So, das ist die Matheaufgabe. Wie viel Dezibel Stimmkraft musst du aufbringen, wenn ein Auto mit 40 kmh an dir, während du mit relativer Geschwindigkeit von, nee, nicht relativ. Vor allem, wie schnell musst du klopfen, dass du noch die klassischen drei Klopfer auf der Kühlerhaube unterbringst, wenn das Auto mit 57 kmh an dir vorbeifährt.
Weil bis zu drei Klopfen ist es kein Klopfen.
Ist eher ein Oh.
Aber das ist erstmal komisch, wenn du zu Hause sitzt und es gibt so ein...
Das ist ja so merkwürdig. Das ist merkw komisch, wenn du zu Hause sitzt, dann gibt's so ein ... Dö-dün, dö-dün, dö-dün.
Das ist ja so merkwürdig.
Das ist merkwürdig, ne?
Einmal klopfen ist gar nichts.
Einmal klopfen ist, a, das war die Heizung.
Aber hast du nicht auch diese Spannungsgefühle in dir, wenn du das machst?
Ja.
Ja, das ist okay, alles mehr, mehr ist okay. Vier ist mehr, vier ist okay okay. Drei ist finde ich auch noch schon ein bisschen wenig. Ja, vier ist wahrscheinlich die gängigste Klopfvariante. Die Tür. Bam, bam, bam, bam. Interessant, ne? Wie viel Zeit hätte man sparen können, wenn man einfach immer nur dreimal klopft? Glaubst du, das ist auch so kulturell unterschiedlich? Oder mit der Faust. Bam, bam, bam, bam. Eins und vier wahrscheinlich. In Deutschland sind wir eher vier. Aber glaubst du? Das ist ein Vierviertelland. Das ist ein Vierviertelland. Das schlägt sich in der Musik wieder. Manche Menschen in verschiedenen Ländern begrüssen sich ja mit einem Kuss. So rechts, links. Können wir aber auch machen. Oder rechts, links. Nee, ich wollte nur gerade das Beispiel sagen. Ja, aber das können wir ja auch einfielen. Ja, ja, aber lass mich kurz zu Ende erzählen. Erstmal viermal oder so. Oder manche machen es sehr lang. Das können wir auch lang machen, das ist ja okay. Manche machen es gar nicht. Okay. Hat man sich schon gut kennt? Möchtest du dich küssen? Ich finde es halt eine nette Geste. Fändest du es besser, wenn wir uns küssen würden für jede Begrüßung? Ich würde es auch mal ausprobieren. Okay, ist es eher neutral, oder es klingt so, als würdest du schon eher drauf bestehen? Wenn es halt die kulturelle Vorstellung ist, okay, wer bin ich mich dagegen? Weil ich glaube, glaubst du, je mehr sich Länder küssen, desto weniger wird geklopft. Also sich liebendere Länder. Glaubst du da eigentlich? Korrelation. Korrelation. Der Küssklopf-Multiplikator. Ich bin auf der Suche nach Korrelationen, mit denen so niemand rechnet. Verstehst du? Also dass es eine Gesamtmenge gibt, die muss man aufteilen in Küsse und Klopfen. Ich dachte nur gerade, die Deutschen küssen sich nicht und klopfen viel. Ich dachte, sagt das was über uns aus? Direkt, nicht romantisch. Wir wollen rein. Und Tür auf. Ich klopfe lieber direkt doll, damit man die Tür aufmacht. Und dann begrüsse ich dich mit einem Handschlag. Das ist Deutschland. Ich dachte, das hängt zusammen. Und in Frankreich ist vielleicht... Ich finde, man darf es auch nicht zu sehr übertreiben, weil am Ende fängt man an, die Tür zu küssen. Das ist halt, ich glaube, das ist das grösste mehr. Ich glaube, da gibt es manche Kulturen, die untergegangen sind, weil die einfach gar nicht mehr zur Tür reingekommen sind, weil es einfach nicht funktioniert hat. Das stimmt schon. Oder Steintüren hatten, man hört Klopfen schlicht nicht. Steintüren waren generell, glaube ich, in der Geschichte der Menschheit ein großes Problem. Ne, also ich sag mal so, damals die Inka und so, Steinpyramiden, Steinhäuser. Stimmt, aber eine Steintür? Aus einem grossen Stein? Ja, und dann wurde die immer von zwei Riesen aufgezogen. Troll, aber ich meine bei Jesus gab es ja diese kultige Steinplatte, die man gerollt hat. Ja genau, es gab da, und scheißiß Iconic. Iconic, Kult, Classic, Design-Klassiker. Ich will die auch als Funko-Pop haben. Ich glaube, ein großer Steinball, letztlich. Ein Ball? Ich dachte eher wie so eine große Scheibe. Aber war das eine Standard-Tür zu der Zeit, oder hat man damit Gräber verschlossen? Nee, es war der Klassiker, den wollten alle haben. Was die Monstera-Pflanze, der damals, was die Monstera-Pflanze heute für Pflanzen ist, war das damals die Tür.
So ein gängiges, so ein, was alle gerade haben. Da gab es dann einen Steinmetz in Benetekel, der hat die dann ikonisch gemacht.
Erst gab es einen, richtig, und dann haben alle den nachgemacht, teilweise hohl innen drin, um Materialkosten zu sparen.
Ich verstehe.
Die haben einen Stein, diesen Donut-shaped Stein, aber als Sphäre. Ach so. Und innen drin war der aber hohl. Ach, das ist jetzt schon. Jetzt habe ich mich kurz verdacht. Jetzt habe ich mich kurz in den Krampf gedacht. Ja, apropos lustiges Verdenken. Ich war zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben in einem Escape Room. Meine Familie hat ... Und die Tatsache, dass du heute hier sitzt, sagt mir doch, da ist alles glimpflich verlaufen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Familien in Escape Rooms gelassen werden. Sonst hätten wir eine Skype-Folge machen müssen. Ja, hi, ich bin noch im Escape Room. Es gibt hier einen blauen, einen grünen und einen gelben Knopf. Und ich bin noch nicht so weit. Und jetzt nachtest du die Folge aufnehmen. Lass uns das einfach ignorieren. Ich habe zumindest das WLAN-Passwort schon rausbekommen. Das habe ich hingekriegt. Lass uns nicht darauf eingehen, okay, in der Folge, dass ich in dem Escape Room sitze. Können wir das ignorieren, Frau Routin? Okay, Stefan, ja, machen wir. Wenn im Hintergrund jemand ruft irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, das Tor des Barboxers. Code One fährt-Faird, Code-Word-Faird, nee, passt nicht, sind nur drei Buchstaben. Ignorier die Schreie im Hintergrund und so. Der Sauerstoff geht ganz langsam aus. Wie viele Tiere mit drei Buchstaben gibt's? U, hast du ein U? V, V, V, V, V, V. V, ich ... Also, und das war, wir haben es unserem Onkel geschenkt, also meinem Onkel, er ist nicht von jedem in der Familie Onkel, sondern mein Onkel, aber der Familie, meine Bezeichnung relativ zu ihm als Verwandten ist Onkel. Alle haben ihm das geschenkt und wir haben, ich war es erst mal im Escape Room. Ich glaube nicht, dass man das dazu sagen muss, wenn du sagst, meine Mutter, also nur meine Mutter, nicht für alle. Ich habe vorher gesagt, wir haben es unserem Onkel geschenkt. Das klang so, als ob alle, die ihm das geschenkt haben, und es klang, als wäre das. Habe ich gar nicht so drauf geachtet, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, aber okay. Nee, okay, ich wollte nur sagen, unser Stammbaum ist ganz normal. Okay. Also so die komplett normalen, bei Normen sprechen. Ganz normaler Standard, so wie so wie so ein Ahornbaum. Normaler Baum, würde nicht auffallen in dem normalen Baum. Wenn man den anderen Stammbäumen sehen, die auch sehr normal sind, würde der nicht auffallen als andersartig oder mit grossartigen Ausnahmen. Außer die üblichen, die man halt eh hat. Ja, der eine oder andere hat sich. Also die ist halt die Wahrscheinlichkeit. Genau, also gut. Und wir haben den Escape Room gemacht und es war voll cool und es gab halt dann so einen Studi, so einen Studenten, der dann da vorher uns das erklärt hat, wie das überhaupt funktioniert. Und er hat natürlich gesagt, er hat da so ein bisschen auch Schauspielertätigkeiten dann ausführen müssen. Und hat dann... Wo du immer mit Leuten interagierst, die eine Rolle spielen. Ja, ich lieb das ja. Und dann hat er sich dann hingestellt und gesagt, so, jetzt geht hier in den Raum rein, für mich ist die Aufgabe hier vorbei, ich gehe in unseren Surveillance-Van und gebe euch von da Tipps. Ganz toll gemacht, supergut, die Immersion stimmt, er hat es gut erklärt, warum er nicht dabei ist, er geht hinten in diesen Control-Ro Room, sieht uns über die Kameras, was glaube ich der beste Job aller Zeiten ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Leute, ich glaube es macht zwei Tage Arbeit und nur Spaß, habe ich auch schon drüber nachgedacht und irgendwann siehst du halt, Leute machen immer den gleichen Fehler. Leute sind dumm, Leute kommen nicht auf dieses eine Rätsel, bla bla bla. Und es war so ein FBI thematisches Ding, oder was war das Thema? Das Thema war ein bisschen Ocean's Eleven-artig.
Wir sind sozusagen Heistist Con-Artists, sind in einen Raum von einem Casino-Besitzer eingebrochen, um dem eine Lektion zu erpressen. Und dringen seinen privaten Raum vor, um dann da den Tresor zu öffnen. Das Ziel war den Tresor zu öffnen. Okay. Und sind dann da rein. Und es war voll, so wie man das vorstellt, lief alles gut, ein paar Tipps bekommen von ihm und so. Ich glaub, das ist auch normalerweise nicht genau. Und er hat es immer gut hingekriegt, wenn wir nicht weiterkamen. Und erst mal dachte ich auch, wir müssen funktionieren. Weil wenn die Familie nicht funktioniert, ist irgendwie ... Also danach können wir uns nicht mehr in die Augen gucken. Weil danach, wenn man Weihnachtenachten zusammensetzt und alle erzählen von den Jobs, denkt man, ja, du erzählst es von deinem Job, aber ich weiss, dass du ein fucking Loser bist. Wir sind alles ... Ich weiss, dass du den gelben Juwel in das Loch für den blauen gesteckt hast, obwohl es offensichtlich nicht dem Farbcode entsprochen hat. Und dann Weihnachten nach so drei Wein so ... Halt doch alle die Klappe! Wir haben ... Wir haben ... Wir Hier mit drei Buchstaben, da gibt's halt nicht so viel! Wir sind alles Versager. Ihr könnt euch erzählen, wie ihr das Jahr über verbracht habt und wie viele Verdienter und was für coole Erfolge ihr habt in dem Beruf. Stefan, Stefan, Stefan, legt das Weinglas weg. Ich wusste nicht, wie man Lux schreibt, okay? Legt das Weinglas weg. Nein! Wir machen dir was vor, wir können nichts. Und deswegen gehen wir nächstes Jahr. Deswegen habe ich hier Gutscheine für euch alle hier.
Nein! Deswegen gehen wir nochmal dahin. Und wenn wir das diesmal nicht in der Stunde schaffen, dann war es das mit der Familie, okay? Okay, ich kann es so nicht weiterleben. Okay! Ja, und so, deswegen habe ich gedacht, wir müssen funktionieren, das muss beim ersten Mal klappen. Und dann, und immer wenn quasi uns Tipps gegeben wurden,
war es total cool, hat der Studie das geschafft,
in der Immersion zu schaffen, zu halten und zu sagen,
keine Ahnung, versuch doch mal das und das Team.
Team, habt ihr schon mal darüber nachgedacht, das und das zu machen?
Er hat sich das Wort Team benutzt.
Und dann aber ich natürlich durch den Raum gelaufen
und alles auseinandergenommen und habe dann unterm Kamin so eine Klappe gefunden, wo so ein ferngestelltes Auto drin stand. Und dann habe ich das da rausgenommen, das aus dem unten raus, das war sehr schwergängig und dachte mir schon, okay, und dann habe ich es rausgenommen und das war der erste Moment, wo er nicht mehr in der Immersion, im Plot sein konnte und dann gesagt hat, ja, das musst du einfach wieder zurückstellen. Nee, das bitte einfach wieder zurückstellen. Ähm, danke. Und ich ... okay. Okay, Team Captain. Okay, Team Captain, warum soll ich's wieder zurückstellen? Hä? Was für eine weird Aussage, Team Captain? Moment, aber da ist ein vergestelltes Auto, das nicht Teil des Escape-Rooms ist. Doch, doch, doch. Aber es soll da drin bleiben. Ja, genau. Es soll da drin bleiben und dann kann man das dann fahren blind, während andere im Nebenraum sehen, wo in Richtung du steuern musst, dann muss man da miteinander zusammenarbeiten und so. Okay. Und ich fand das aber so lustig, weil die ganze Zeit davor hat es geklappt, aber niemand, und die haben ja mit sehr viel Eventualität wahrscheinlich schon gerechnet, und das viel, keine Ahnung, dann kannst du halt manche Schrauben aufmachen und die anderen sind rund. Die sind so rundpulliert, dass du da gar nichts dran machen kannst. Also der Raum ist equipped, auch, ich glaube auch die Feuermelder sind so doppelt vermietet und sowas, damit da nichts passieren kann, weil alle, und er hat auch am Anfang gesagt, alles über zwei Meter oben, bitte einfach weg drü. Und wir haben... Ist da ein Hinweis drin, was ist das für ein komisches Ventil, dass der Feuermelder... Bitte einfach den Feuermelder in Ruhe lassen, danke schön. Vielleicht finden wir da noch den geheimen Schlüssel, dass der Feuermelder bitte nicht abschrauben. Er hat auch vorher gesagt, ist sehr warm gerade, deswegen haben wir einen Ventilator reingestellt. Der hat nichts mit dem ganzen, der ganze Story zu tun. Und dann stand ich aber davor und dachte mir, war das schon Teil der Illusion. Ach so, okay, der Irreführung, ja, verstehe. Weil dann war der große und große Ventilator da drin, so eine Klimaanlage, und die war halt Casino-Gebrand, weil die wollten die nicht einfach so da reinstellen, sondern die haben dann da so ein Ass, wie so eine Spielkarte so draufgeklebt. Dann dachte ich mir, why would they do this, und warum ist es ein Ass? Das ist nur ein Ventilator, weil es heiß ist. Nein, bitte einfach ignorieren. Ich finde das aber so lustig, weil alle waren die ganze Zeit so in game und es war cool und die Zeit lief runter und es wurde spannend und die Story war geil und dann einfach, nee, kannst du es bitte einfach wieder zurückstellen. Und ich dachte mir, das gibt es doch jetzt nicht. Wie habe ich das denn jetzt, wie habe ich das zerstört, weil ich bin doch immer ein Fan von von Immersion, du bist drin, von Immersion, ich will doch die Story und ich bei Jurassic Park und so, deswegen werde ich ja so enttäuscht, weil ich will die ja erhalten und dann war ich plötzlich ursächlich davon, weil ich das so rausgenommen habe, dieses Auto, dass es dann irgendwie kaputt gegangen ist, aber gut. Aber wie viele Familien da schon kaputt gegangen sind. Hab ich auch gedacht. Und vor allem, ich fände es auch gut, wenn der irgendwann anfängt, nicht mehr nur so Game-Tipps zu geben, sondern auch also beziehungsfamilientechnische Tipps. Hey Team, vielleicht könnt ihr eurer Mutter nicht vielleicht jedes Mal ins Wort fallen, wenn sie versucht, einen Tipp zu geben. Ja gut, aber sie macht ja seit einer halben Stunde Sitz hier hinten an diesem Computer, um so das Passwort rauszubekommen. Hey Team, ich sehe hier gerade auf meinem Sensor, dass vielleicht eine narzisstische Persönlichkeitsstörung im Raum ist.
Wollt ihr vielleicht darüber mal reden?
Wollen wir vielleicht darüber mal reden? Nur so als Tipp.
Oh Gott, das ist ja sehr, das war Krapfot.
Genau so ist es eigentlich.
Also ich habe versucht, ich habe gedacht, das Potenzial,
dass ich da unangenehm auffalle, ist relativ gross.
Ja.
Weil ich glaube, ich in solchen Situationen dazu neige,
schon, ich möchte schon schnell dann fertig, also ich möchte schon eine gute Zeit aufstellen. Ja, okay, ich verstehe. Und wenn dann da jemand nur rumsteht und so ... Oder keine Ahnung, das haben wir ja gerade schon ausprobiert. Oder da hat jemand nicht genau aufgepasst, dass da ja gerade schon jemand das Rätsel bereits gelöst hat. Ne, dann ... Aber ich hab mich, weil ich das wusste, hab ich eher überkompensiert. Und ich war eher, der rumstand und gesagt hat, you go, Team. Ja, ihr macht das. Aber ich fand das super, es hat echt viel Spaß gemacht. Also, ich finde, man ist jetzt sollte wieder ... Es gab Escape-Rooms, war ein Riesen-Hype, dann gab's diesen Hate-Teil, den es immer gibt, Hate-Rooms. Und jetzt finde ich, man sollte wieder darüber hinwegsehen, sondern als Team Building ... Es ist bereit für die nächste Phase, es geht wieder rein, um rauszukommen. Ich finde, es ist wieder okay. Ich finde, wir alle können Escape-Rooms wieder cool finden, weil für ein Familienevent ist das nicht schlecht. War lustig, kleine Rätsel, die haben Spaß gemacht. Ja, meine Familie, wir haben mal versucht, eine lange Stange hochzuheben. Hey Team, wollt ihr euch eurer Mutter mal helfen, diese lange Stange hochzuheben, weil sonst die Idee war, man hat, das ist so ein klassisches Teambuilding-Ding, die Idee war, man hat so eine ganz lange Stange, aber man darf die nur so auf die Finger drauflegen, man darf die nicht nehmen, sondern nur so drauflegen und man darf auch keinen Abstand haben. Das heißt, man muss gemeinsam mit einer gemeinsamen Bewegung die hochheben, was nahezu unmöglich ist, weil jeder hat eine andere Geschwindigkeit und dann geht man wieder zurück und dann dürfen die anderen nicht hochheben und das ist absolut unmöglich. Und man sieht einfach aus, wie die absolut unfähigste Gruppe Menschen, die jemals zusammengekommen ist, weil man einfach nur darstellt und sagt, ja, Hora, mach du, drei, zwei, eins, hoch, ja, so. Und ich hab einfach nur gelacht. Ich fand's so lustig einfach, wie auch wirklich innerhalb dieser Emotionsgraf einfach so rapide hochsteigt. So, ja, wir probieren es mal, na ja, kommt nochmal. Ist ja auch egal, oder? Okay, oh, okay, alles klar. Okay, Mama, bitte, du musstest, mein Gott, ihr könnt ja nicht einfach mal zusammen hochgehen! Einfach so instant. Und dann ist es so, wei, ja geht jetzt aber schnell. Das ist das spielerische Äquivalent zu einer Couch in einen Raum tragen. Oder noch besser, aus einem Raum raustragen. Weil eine Couch in einen Raum reintragen, wenn es nicht klappt, okay, Tür ist wahrscheinlich zu schmal. Aber wenn ein Möbelstück im Raum steht, hat es ja mal geklappt. Und dann muss man damit raustragen, so beim Umzug helfen, man trägt Möbel raus, blödere Step dafür nämlich. Ja, ja. Es hat ja schon mal auch geklappt. Genau. Und dann so, nee, dreh noch ein bisschen, dreh noch ein bisschen, ich hab auch gesagt, dreh noch ein bisschen, du siehst doch, in welche Richtung ich dreh. Aber du siehst doch, du siehst doch, du kannst aufhören zu drücken, du siehst doch, dass es mein Gegenurzeiger sind. Aber du siehst doch, dass es nicht klappt von der Breite her. Aber du siehst ja gerade, in welche Richtung ich es kippe. Ja, aber es funktioniert nicht von der Breite, weil es breit ist. Und abstehen, abstehen, abstehen. Mein Gott. Kann es sein, dass die das Haus um diese Couch herum gebaut haben? Können wir noch mal kurz in die Pläne gucken? Es gab so eine Zeit, wo Bäume ähnlich geschützt wurden wie Couches. Und da hat man um Häuser, um gute Couches rumgebaut. Die haben die Couch in die Luft geworfen und dann im dritten Stock das Haus sozusagen drumrum gebaut. Das war so die Idee. Man hat es schnell gebaut, musste aber nur eine Decke einziehen. Man hat es hochgeworfen und die Decke reingezogen. Einmal drüber. Ja, I don't know. Es ist auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, die Familie ist weder gestärkt noch geschwächt rausgegangen, also sehr neutral. Ich glaube aber primär durch dieses, es ist ja offensichtlich ein Spiel, weil der hat gerade gesagt, dass man das Auto zurückstellen soll. Was man, dann habe ich auch überlegt, wie hätte er das sagen können, ohne dass die Story verloren geht. Ja, ja. No chance. Hey, Agent S, hinterlass keine Fingerabdrücke am besten. Mhm, okay... Stell's am besten wieder zurück, damit wir keine Spuren hinterlassen, Agent S. Ah ja, okay, nee, eigentlich gut. Ja, aber wir klauen ja die Sache. Was habt ihr geklaut, Diamanten oder Geldsack? Nee, es ging eher darum, den Tresor, den Tresor-Code herauszufinden, um ihm zu zeigen, dass wir das können. Und ich weiß nicht genau, was hat man mal gesagt. Okay, doch so eine Story. Okay, wir wollen nur ein Statement setzen. Also wir könnten Terry Benedict ausrauben, wenn wir wollten, aber wir machen es nicht. Weil wir die moralische Oberhand haben und er die Casino-Besucher schon ausraubt, weil seine Maschinen irgendwie ... Nein, sag nicht, die Maschinen sind so eingestellt, dass die Bank mehr verdient. Hör auf jetzt. Ich weiß, Riesenskandal. So ein Schwein. Das kann nicht sein. Ja. Dass das erlaubt ist, dass das erlaubt ist, dass der Besitzer des Casinos mehr verdient als derjenige, der dran spielt. Das ist ein Riesens Leute quasi raus. Das ist ein Riesenskandal. Ja. Das müssen wir ihn an die Öffentlichkeit bringen. Ja, genau. Ich würde sagen, wir müssen deswegen aber erst in sein Privatgemach einbrechen, um ihm zu zeigen, dass wir es können und dann erpressen. Aber obwohl er moralisch verwelte Dinge tut, klauen wir ihm nicht sein erklautes Geld. Ne, genau, weil Klauen von jemandem, der es geklaut hat, ist auch Klauen. Okay, alles klar. Weil es auch Selbstjustiz, okay. Okay, ready? Okay, T-Mitteilbuchstaben. Habt ihr es verstanden? Und dann so drei Sechsjährige, die mich einen angucken und sagen, können wir reingehen? Uns interessiert der Plot nicht so. Wir wollen den Plot, den dramaturgischen Arc nicht so gern mitverfolgen.
Uns interessiert die Charakterzeichen und das Antagonisten nicht so.
Ich brauche kein Break into Three, der Plotbombe ist mir egal.
Da wir können hier auf den Save the Cat-Moment verzichten, ich will nur das Rätsel machen.
The Dark Knight of the Souls ist der am wenigsten Lieblingsmoment des Films. Ob es eine Dreiaktstruktur ist oder vier, ist mir egal. Klar ist der Mentor wichtig, aber muss er wirklich sterben, damit er seine Lektionen lernt? Weiss ich nicht. Kindergartengruppen sind am anstrengendsten, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen. Können die Eltern mit den drei Mädels reingehen? Ich kenne die nicht. Wie alt muss man sein für Escape Rooms? Oh, das weiß ich nicht. Aber ich glaube, ab einem gewissen Punkt ist natürlich immer die Frage bei Kindern, inwiefern checken die, was los ist und was nicht? Oder inwiefern denken die wirklich, die sind jetzt in der Bank oder da passiert irgendwas? Und dann sind schon auch dumm. Dann haben sie vergessen, den Zettel der Zeit, also die Urkunde der Familie, die ja vorher, oder Freundeskreis, die ja vordrin waren, wegzuräumen. Und die haben 57 Minuten gebraucht. Eine Stunde hat man Zeit, das glaubt man immer ein bisschen darauf hinaus. Ja, genau. Und mein Ziel war die ganze Zeit nur schneller als die zu sein. Schneller als diese Drecksschneiders. Vielleicht legen die das extra da rein. Unsere Feindesfamilie. Vor uns waren die Rivalen. Die kam alle so Polohemden, so weisse Polo-Einnamen gehabt, alle so Familienoutfits. Und dann sind sie dann so rausgekommen, vorher so mega stolz.
Ja, da habe ich auch noch ein schönes Artefakt. Da war ich mal nämlich in München in der BMW World. Da gibt es ja so ein großes BMW-Gebäude und da war man irgendwie drin und da gab es dann so einen Fahrsimulator, wo man sich da so reinsetzen könnte und dann konntest du da irgendwie so eine Strecke fahren und je nachdem wie gut du die Strecke gefahren bist, hast du am Ende wie so eine Art Foto auf so einem Fotopapier bekommen mit deiner Punktzahl und ein Bild, das von dir gemacht wurde in diesem Simulator drin. und dann, Maximalpunkte waren 10.000 und ich fahre da durch links, rechts, versuch es richtig
gut zu schaffen und dann habe ich 7.800
Punkte, ah verdammt, naja,
nimm die Karte und ich da so, sitze da
irgendwie ein angespanntes Gesicht im Simulator und dann
sehe ich, oh, da richtig gut zu schaffen. Und dann habe ich 7800 Punkte. Ah, verdammt, naja, nimm die Karte und ich da so, sitze da irgendwie ein angespanntes Gesicht im Simulator und dann sehe ich, oh, da liegt noch eine andere Karte drin, von der Person vor mir. Oh, okay. Und dann nehme ich die Karte raus und es ist so eine etwas ältere Frau, zum Schal und so einer spitzen Brille, die so relativ verwirrt guckt, null Punkte. Oh nein! Das ist perfekt. Ich hatte siebentausend von zehntausend und sie hatte null. Und diese Karte habe ich bis heute, weil ich liebe dieses, auch dieser Blick dieses, ja ich habe null. Ich versuch's, ich versuch's. Ich probier's mal, ich bin mit meinem Sohn hier und ich probier's auch, null. Eber nie. Gnadenlos. Schreibt dann zumindest so eine Mindest, weil wenn da steht, niemand weiß von wie viel erreichbarer Punkte, wenn da null steht, versagen. 2000 ist das Minimum. Jeder kriegt erstmal 2000. Selbst wenn du 200 reinschreibst, denkt man, oh, sie hat 200 Punkte geschafft, ich kenne ja die Skala nicht, ich weiß nicht, was das Ziel war, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was für ein Gerät das war. Aber wenn da Nullpunkte steht, Nullpunkte sagt, immer aus, sie hat es nicht geschissen bekommen, vermutlich ist sie nicht mehr losgefahren. Und ich frage mich bis heute, hat sie dieses Foto dann genommen und angeguckt und gesagt, das lasse ich hier, das brauche ich nicht, oder hat sie es gar nicht erst rausgenommen? Weil sie ganz anders reagiert, als mein Ding nachgesagt,, dann werbe ich meinen Traum der Rennfahrerin wohl weg. Schatz, wir fahren nicht zum Nürburgring nächste Woche. Mama, du bist 56 Jahre alt, du bist gelernte Erzieherin, warum willst du jetzt anfangen plötzlich Rennen zu fahren, das war auch noch nie dein Traum. Ich dachte, dass ich mindestens 1000 kriege, aber null, null. Mama, das ist doch jetzt nicht so schlimm, du warst nie interessiert an Rennfahren oder sowas,
du hast nie davon erzählt.
Ich glaube, ich hätte es schaffen können.
Du hast nicht immer einen Führerschein.
Das hätte ich ja alles noch gemacht, aber...
Wie, warum ist das plötzlich dein Traum?
Ich habe anscheinend kein Talent dafür.
Ich liebe die Geschwindigkeit.
Seit wann?
Wir sind jetzt 20 Minuten hier...
Und deiner Mutter steckt mehr, als du vielleicht denkst.
Ja, auch ich habe Träume.
Ja, das glaube ich schon auch. Ich habe auch Träume, ja. Okay, was willst du noch werden? Astronautin? Hatte ich null Punkte leider. Null Punkte? Ja, es ... Sie liebt Dinge, die sie nicht kann. Ich mag diese Idee, dass man das abschließt, null Punkte geht, und dann so, während man so traurig weggeht, so ein Close-Up, so ein ... Kommt dieses gedruckte Ding da raus, fällt so in den Frame, null Punkte. Glaubst du, die war da schon weg oder hast du noch gesehen, hast du dann da hingeworfen? Falls ihr diese Person seid und vor 15 Jahren in der BMW World in München wart und vielleicht nicht den besten Punktestand bekommen habt, schreibt mir gerne, dann können wir das vielleicht rekonstruieren. Und wir können ja dafür sorgen, wir können veranlassen, dass sie das nochmal fahren und sie vielleicht einen besseren Punktestand kriegen. Wir würden das in die Hand nehmen, dass sie den kostenlosen Eintritt bezahlt bekommen in die BMW World. Wir würden uns darum kümmern, dass das alles so funktioniert, dass da niemand ihnen im Weg steht an dem Simulator und dann können sie das nochmal fahren und vielleicht haben sie die Möglichkeit, das nochmal besser zu machen. BMW World klingt für mich enttäuscht, nach einer Enttäuschung. Findest du nicht? Nach Marvel World und Harry Potter World meinst du, oder was? Nee, es klingt wie sowas, wo man hingeht, der Eintritt ist frei, man wird schon skeptisch und denkt, naja, okay, bin gespannt, was es hier für Attraktionen gibt. Der Vater will eigentlich ganz gerne hin oder die Mutter, aber man selber guckt sich dann als Kind so um und sieht, dann ist da halt dieser Simulator, der ist geil, aber davor ist eine Riesenschlange, dann ist da hinten Waffelstand, aber die sieht so aus, als würde man davon nicht essen wollen, weil man eine Lebensmittelvergiftung bekommt. Und dann stehen da sehr viele alte BMW-Modelle ausgestellt, die sich niemand leisten kann und oder auch die einem egal sind, die man auch nicht so schick findet, die haben eine Historie, daneben ist so eine kleine Plakette.
Da läuft so ein Film in Endlosschleife aus den BMW-Werken.
Genau, oder BMW-Werbung und so und dann ist da eine Maschine, die sind auto-assembled vielleicht und dann geht man da 20 Minuten rum, aber der ganze Sonntag hat man sich dafür vorgenommen.
Heute ist der BMW-World-Sonntag und man ist dann da und dann guckt man sich die Schlange an als Kind und denkt sich, what have I become? Corporate Bitch. Das bin jetzt ich, oder was? Kostenloser Eintritt zu so einer eigentlich Werbeveranstaltung. Marken-Fanboy. Am Ende gesetzt sich der Kapitalismus dann doch überall durch. Aber das fände ich gut, wenn bei generell solchen Veranstaltungen einfach immer so eine Minutenanzahl dabei steht. Bei so einem Das grosse Bogenbacher Stadtfest, schön mit Ritterumzug, Waffel und Duftkerzen verkauft, Dauer 18 Minuten. Geil für eine halbe Stunde. Ich will so eine Geil für. Genau, Geil für, GF. Eine GFT,
also Geil für Zeit.
GFT 18 Minuten. Genau,
Geil für 18 Minuten. OkayFT
40 Minuten. Oh, jetzt wird's weird.
Und dann so maximal, also wenn
du unbedingt Zeit totschlagen musst, wie viel
Zeit kannst du maximal dort verbringen?
Wenn ihr euch in der Beziehung wirklich nichts mehr zu
sagen habt, so, und
Sonntage, sind Sonntage die Qual? Habt ihr euch euch nichts mehr zu sagen, dann kommt zu uns, zur Bogenbracher Bogenschießwelt. Auch World, World, kommt alle mal wieder runter, World, ihr macht Autos. Ich habe drei Stände und so einen Raclette-Stand und eine Bühne, wo der Kinderchor singt, okay? Ihr macht Autos. Ja, runter. Bisschen runter. BMW Town. Ja, ja, guck mal, so was. BMW Tower. Ja, Tower. Ja, da gibt es auch einen grossen Turm, da kann es einen auch hoch. Ist schon geil, ist schon geil. In der ganzen Gegend, Olympiastadion und so. Ah, ist das alles deine Liebe? Das ist schon alles nett. Da kannst du nichts sagen. Das ist heute Minga, gell? Das ist Minga, das ist Minga. Das gehört dazu. Wollen wir mal eine Folge machen, wo du mir bayerisch beibringst, die ganze Folge. Du sagst das richtig vor und ich mach es schlecht nach. Ich glaube, dass der was für Pet werden, glaube ich, ist ein anderes Wort, das wirst du eine Scheissidee. Das ist eher der unbeliebter Teil. Ja, okay, nee, ich war nur ein kleiner, so eine Idee, ich weiß nicht. Jetzt, wo wir uns nicht mehr zu sagen haben, wollen wir auch mal in die BMW World. Du, lass uns gerne einen Podcast aus der BMW World machen. Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an das Museum, was es in Dortmund gab. Aber in Dortmund gibt es nicht so wahnsinnig viele Museen. Inzwischen gibt es mehr, inzwischen gibt es, wenn ich kulturell, hat sich da viel getan im Ruhrgebiet, will ich ja gar nicht sagen. Früher war das ein bisschen anders und es gab nur ein richtig geiles Museum in Dortmund und das war die Deutsche Arbeitsschutzausstellung. Sperriger Name, sperriges Thema, sperriges Musik. Liebe Arbeitsschutz! Aber ich hab's geliebt. Das war so ein tolles Museum.
Der Name ist ja dermaßen abschreckend. Heute gehen wir in die Deutsche Arbeitsschutzausstellung. Habt ihr da Bock? Ja. Und Klein Stefan hat gesagt, bitte was? Ihr wollt, dass ich meine Nintendo weglege? Für was? Arbeitsschutz? Deutsche Arbeitsschutzausstellung? Und ich hab auch so gedacht, in Amerika wäre das kein Thema. Wollen wir ein Arbeitsschutzmuseum? Nein. Wollen wir überhaupt Arbeitsschutz machen? Nein. Und in Deutschland ist das einfach ein fucking Museum. Man ist so proud darauf, dass man daraus ein Museum macht. Und da hat auch sehr viel über Dortmund auch so, Arbeiterkultur, bla bla bla. Und das war aber ein richtig, richtig geiles Museum. Also unglaublich cool, weil die haben zum Beispiel das Innere eines AKWs komplett Modell eins zu eins, den Kontrollraum nachgebaut und du konntest dich halt da hinsetzen an so ein AKW und halt alle Knöpfe drücken. Oh geil. Mega cool. Oben im gleichen Raum hing auch ein Helikopter, der war so an so zwei Schrauben befestigt und hing dann aber so, dass du quasi reingehen konntest und aussieht, als ob du gerade so fliegst. Und es war auch super cool. Dann gab es eine Geisterbahn, die damit gespielt hat, dass eine Lagerhalle nicht den deutschen Arbeitsschutzmassnahmen entspricht. Man fährt halt rum und überall kippen so Regale um und oben oben kommt dann so etwas wirklich, viele Near-Misses, habe ich gelernt, aus Freizeitpark-Videos und Reviews. Also total geil. Man konnte einen Gabelstapler-Führerschein machen. Das waren alles coole Dinge. Und die hat super viel Spaß gemacht, diese ganze Ausstellung war richtig geil. Eine Geisterbahn für nicht eingehaltene Sicherheitsprotokolle ist ja wirklich fantastisch. Die Leiter ist nicht gesichert, die Leiter ist nicht gesichert. Oh Gott, zum Glück, das war keine echte Leiter. Man kommt raus und will zum TÜV. Man will TÜV Süd, man will da einfach unterschreiben, sign me up. Das Ölfass ist nicht richtig markiert, was will... Oh, sorry. Okay, Entschuldigung, ich dachte, die hätten wirklich das Ölfass nicht ordnungsgemäß markiert. Und dann war einmal lustig, dann bin ich da hin und die Geisterbahn war immer das Highlight für mich, weil dann war die Geisterbahn geschlossen. Das war der eigentliche Horror. Und dann habe ich mir aber auch jetzt gerade gedacht, weil da was passiert ist. Also was ist in der Geisterbahn für schlechte Arbeitsschutzmassnahmen passiert? Der Geisterwagen ist entgleist. Ja, entweder entgleist oder ist so ein Fass wirklich runtergefallen? Obwohl, das wäre die perfekte Immersion, wenn der Wagen entgleist und das aber nur ein Fake ist. Okay, Entschuldigung, wir müssen den nochmal anhalten, der Wagen ist entgleist. Das wäre perfekt. Und dann so, ah, da hat anscheinend jemand die Schrauben nicht richtig zugezogen. Zieht immer die Schrauben richtig zu. Zack, war da geht's. Wow, wow, wow, es war von Anfang an geplant. Ey, ohne Scheiß, aber das wirklich. Museen können so geil sein. Und ich habe schon so viele Museen mit coolem Thema besucht, die nicht gut waren. Und das ist wirklich ein Museum mit dem sperrigsten Thema der ganzen, ganzen Welt. Es macht ja Spaß, so ein AKW-Kontrollraum.
Ich meine, ich weiß nicht genau, was so ein Kind
dann da drin macht, aber dann einfach so.
Auf alle Knöpfe drücken und du spielst halt mit
deinen Leuten, mit deinen Homies, mit denen du da bist.
Genosse Dyatlov, wir können
den Reaktor nicht noch weiter hochfahren.
Sehen Sie nun.
Chernobyl.
Das Spannendste, was je in einem AKW-Kontrollraum. Die achte Klasse des Manfred-Steiner-Gymnasiums präsentiert für sie Tschernobyl. Ich habe gesagt, der Sicherheitstest wird durchgeführt. Aber Sir, Sir, das steht doch so nicht im Protokoll. Das steht doch nicht im Protokoll. Sie haben gesagt, ich soll uns das Protokoll halten, Genosse Stjernjow. Das ist so, genau so war es. Man spielt so Rollenspiel und haut auf alle Knappe. Obwohl in dem deutschen AKW wahrscheinlich, na gut, die Sicherheitsabschaltung ist eher eingeschaltet worden und das ganze Ding wird runtergefahren. Genau, sie können nicht, ist auf Autopilow, sie können nicht, keine Zeit verdrücken, es bringt nichts. Nee, aber du könntest wenig auf den Alarmkopf drücken und dann ist so ein Alarm angegangen, das war schon geil. Aber nicht in echten Feueralarm, auch hier wieder, bitte nicht einen Feueralarm, das ist der echte Feueralarm, bitte. Entschuldigung. Sie haben eine echte Kettenreaktion, Kernschmelze ausgelöst. Das Ding ist angeschlossen. Scherz, Scherz. Aber bitte achten Sie immer auf die deutschen Arbeitsschutzwasser. Aber bitte schon. Scherz, aber bitte auch ganz trocken vorgetragen. Dies war ein Scherz. Dies war ein deutscher Scherz. Ein Dean abgenommener Dean 48 Scherz. Aber bitte halt auch so ganz trocken vorgetragen alles. Dies war ein Scherz. Dies war ein deutscher Scherz. Ein Dean abgenommener Dean 48 Scherz. Juxus. TÜV Joke. TÜV Joke hat es abgenommen. Die haben bestimmt viel Spaß. Ich glaube das auch. Ich würde dann, glaube ich, so eine Melone hinlegen und dann so einen Ziegelstein draufwerfen und dann so diesen Bauarbeiterhelm auf die Melone setzen und dann drauf. Und das, glaube ich, kann man sehr, kann man auch wiederholen. Kann man sehr plastisch, glaube ich. Du brauchst halt eine Menge Melonen. Und dann würdest du das, dass die Kinder das machen können oder würdest du das als Video zeigen die ganze Zeit? Nee, das würde ich das schon live vor Ort machen. Und dann haben die so einen Roboter auch, der war richtig geil, so ein, ja, wie man das aus Autofabriken kennt, so ein richtig grosser Roboter. Und dann haben die den nur genau so, halt mit Glas eingezäunt, wie seine Reichweite ist. Aber der geht halt mega wild und nimmt so Dinge und zeigt es dir und dann macht der Dinge und der sieht auch, wer wo steht und so. und du erstreckst dich ja die ganze Zeit, wenn du genau davor stehst. Richtig geil auch, weil du denkst halt, holy shit, das Ding würde einen einfach umbringen, wenn man da nicht mehr zu nahe kommen würde. Also wirklich, Shoutout die DASA, check die aus. Vielleicht gibt sie noch genau, wahrscheinlich ist die jetzt noch viel geiler, aber die DASA in Dortmund ist wirklich holy shit. Also heute richtig gute Event-Tipps, ne? Also wir haben einmal die BMW World in München, dann die Dasa, Escape Rooms, das ist ja, aber du hast recht, es gibt ja Leute, die müssen ihren Tag füllen, die sitzen nicht den ganzen Tag am Rechner, sondern müssen dann irgendwie mit ihrem Partner was machen, was machen wir am Wochenende, wollen wir nochmal in die Tauchglocke gehen, wollen wir nochmal zur Tauchglocke, ich will mich trennen, wollen wir nochmal zu dem Adlerhorst gehen, noch zu dem Falkner, wir noch mal zu dem Adlerhorst gehen?
Wir waren gestern beim Adlerhorst. Ohne Scheiss, Schatz, warum können wir nicht einfach wie jedes andere Pärchen uns anschweigen und Stranger Things gucken? Man muss manchmal einfach Zeit totschlagen. Zum Beispiel fand ich, also lieber Gruß an unseren Kollegen Christian vom Gefühlte Fakten. Christian Huber. Christian Huber. Und der hat mal
vor langer, langer Zeit getwittert, er hätte im
Fitnessstudio ein Pärchen überhört,
wo der Mann meinte,
du, lass uns da jetzt lieber
nicht drüber reden, sonst haben wir heute Abend nichts mehr
zu reden. Oh mein Gott.
Und dieser Tweet war so,
wie erbärmlich. Aber ich
dachte immer, nee, ich finde das keinen
schlechten Punkt, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil es gibt limitierte Dinge, die man
zu besprechen hat. Und wenn man gerade
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt. erbärmlich, aber ich dachte immer, nee, ich finde das keinen schlechten Punkt, ehrlich gesagt,
weil es gibt limitierte Dinge, die man zu besprechen hat und wenn man gerade
zusammen sagt, okay, jetzt schauen wir uns einen Film an,
zwei Stunden nicht reden
und dann will man,
sonst haben wir heute Abend nichts mehr.
Ich habe noch drei Anekdoten
und ich kann jetzt nicht
raushauen, sonst habe ich heute Abend nichts mehr.
Ich fand das einen durchaus sehr selbstreflektierten Beziehungskommentar, zu sagen, hey, lass uns jetzt schweigen, sonst können wir später nichts mehr reden. Sonst können wir später nicht drüber reden. Und ich weiß, da schwingt eine gewisse Erbärmlichkeit mit, worauf dieser Tweet abgezielt hat, aber ich fand das ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so schlecht, so offen zu sagen, hey, lass uns heute lieber Abend drüber reden, sonst müssen wir uns wieder anschweigen. Aber ich weiß es nicht. Du kannst einfach nicht unendlich viel reden, es geht nicht. Findest du? Ich finde, man kann unendlich viel reden. Ich rede unendlich viel. Klar wird es irgendwann Fühlwörter. Ich sag mal so, es ist ein Unterschied zwischen Gespräche verlängern und Gespräche starten. Ich glaube, man kann Gespräche sehr stark verlängern. Wenn ein Thema im Raum ist, warum werden manche Tiere so unfertig geboren und manche sehr fertig. Manche Tiere kommen zur Welt und müssen sofort selber Nahrung suchen, andere nicht. Andere sind Raupe und werden später Schmetterling. Genau, da kannst du lange drüber reden. Und der Schmetterling wird später ja ein Fuchs. aber es ist was anderes, ein Thema zu starten, aus einer Stille heraus. Brauchst du ja so einen Starter, du brauchst ja so einen Sauerteig, den musst du schon dabei haben. Der Sauerteig, der muss ja schon in ein paar Tagen gereift sein. Und das ist limitiert. Du hast, sag ich mal, so drei Conversation Starter und die sind aber begrenzt, glaube ich. So würde ich es mir vorstellen. Und, ähm, nee, also, er kommt auf an, wo man ist. Aber du kannst nicht aus der Stille heraus einfach unendlich viele Themen aufmachen. Es kommt auf an, wo man ist. Man braucht Eindrücke. Morne hatte ja damals kaum Geld, aber hat trotzdem die schönsten Bilder gemalt. Ist das nicht interessant, dass Künstler auch oft erst nach ihrem Tod die Anerkennung finden? Ja, oder etwas, was aussagt, wie schrecklich man die Situation findet. Glaubst du, Zyankali tötet sofort und schmerzlos, oder ist es eher ein langer, schmerzhafter Prozess? Glaubst du, wenn man sich absichtlich ... Oh, schläft und so ... Hä, was hast du gerade gesagt? In voller Lautstärke? Nee, ich wollte sagen, wenn man sich absichtlich taub machen würde, damit man nichts mehr hört. Meinst du, das wäre dann besser oder schlechter? Warum sagst du das immer, wenn meine Schwiegermutter hier ist? Warum sprichst du das? Nee, ich finde, man kann unendlich viele Dinge aus dem Nichts generieren, aber es heißt aus dem Nichts. Das ist eigentlich genau mein Punkt, nicht aus dem Nichts, sondern aus, wenn du zum Beispiel in der Öffentlichkeit sitzt, in einem Café oder whatever, es kommt auf die Eindrücke an. Deswegen Spaziergänge geil, immer geil, immer was zu besprechen, Cafés sind cool, generell Unternehmungen und deswegen bin ich auch so großer Fan, selbst von schlechten Museen, wie so Corporate BMW Universe, the Automobile Cinematic Universe, selbst das ist geil, weil man da Eindrücke hat, über die man reden kann. Und deswegen, klar, zu Hause sitzen und so, man hat nur so viele Eindrücke in der Wohnung, die interessant und neu sind, dass man plötzlich darüber reden möchte. Aber ich glaube, was hilft, ist eine Begeisterung zu haben für Kleinigkeiten, so eine Seinfeld-eske Begeisterung für die kleinsten Details des Alltags und Eindrücke. Okay, danke, dann schau ich mal, dass ich da dran arbeite. Ne? Und dass das klappt, weil ich hatte jetzt nur drei Sachen. Genau. Und wenn wir jetzt schon besprechen, dann habe ich heute Abend nichts mehr. Okay, dann, ja, können wir ins Café gehen und uns Eindrücke angucken. Oder wir reden einfach jetzt nicht mehr und ... Ja, lass uns vielleicht kurze Pause machen. Ich glaube, es war eher, der Mann wollte ihr sagen ... wir sind jetzt im Sport hier, ich glaube, es war eher eine höfliche Art, hier zu sagen, halt deine Fresse jetzt. Ich kann auf dem Laufband nicht sprechen. Was ich auch völlig legitim finde, aber es ist schon die Frage, wie man es ausdrückt, ja. Ich habe dich im Supermarkt gesehen. Äh, was? Wann? Wann hast du mich, oh nein, ich war bei dir in der Nähe im Supermarkt. Du musst, sag bitte nicht wo, aber ich habe dich am Samstagabend im Supermarkt gesehen. Nein, wie lustig. In meinem Stammsupermarkt. Das ist ja gruselig. Und ich habe dich gesehen, es war interessant, weil ich habe irgendwie nicht gedacht, ah, da ist Stefan, mit dem ich seit acht Jahren podcaste und dreimal in New York war, sondern ich dachte, what the fuck, das ist Stefan Tietze. Das war wirklich ein ganz surrealer Moment. Aber es wäre genauso, wenn du in meinen Supermarkt auftauchen würdest, wäre das genauso merkwürdig. Es war total merkwürdig. Und ich dachte mir natürlich, ah, okay, aber du warst schon so auf dem Weg zur Kasse. Und ich dachte mir, nee, eigentlich habe ich jetzt gar nichts mit ihm zu besprechen. Wenn ich jetzt mit ihm reden würde, hätte ich bei der Podcastaufnahme nichts mehr zu sagen. Aber wie lustig, weil wir kennen uns, würde ich sagen, sehr, sehr gut, sehr, sehr lange, aber halt immer in einem sehr starren Rahmen. Ja. Und ich meine, das ist schon merkwürdig, sich dann plötzlich an einem ganz anderen Ort zu sehen. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es auch so ein bisschen intrusive gewirkt hat, dass ich so plötzlich bei dir dann plötzlich in deiner... Das war mein absoluter Standard-Supermarkt, wo ich so gut wie jeden Tag einkaufe, immer bin. Mag ich es, may I say, kein guter Supermarkt? Ah, ich weiß nicht. Also ich mag ihn schon, ich will es nicht zu präzise beschreiben, aber ich mag ihn tatsächlich ganz gerne, aber ich hab mich natürlich auch so ein bisschen eingewohnt, aber es stimmt schon, die Kassensituation ist nicht ideal. Nicht ideal. Aber es gibt ein paar versteckte Diamanten, die das ganze Wert macht, finde ich. Also wir können gerne mal ein ... Also, ich kann ja mal ... Also ... Nehm ich mal mit. Ja. Nicht mal Zoom-Call. Yeah. Ach so so eine Tour. Nee, aber es ist wirklich so ein ... Da vermischen sich dann so zwei Welten. Es war wie so ein Crossover, wo plötzlich so die private Welt mit der Podcast-Welt so kollidiert. Und ich dachte mir, was würde ich jetzt mit ihm reden? So, oh, Herr Stephan, oh, wie krass du hier. Aber da unterscheiden wir uns sehr, weil ich würde dich sofort ansprechen. Aber ich hätte es auch mega gut gefunden, wenn du mich angesprochen hättest. Ja, ich kam auch gerade vom Bahnhof aus Hamburg, das heißt, ich hatte meinen Kleiderbeutel noch an, Kopfhörer, ich war wirklich wie so auf so einer Nepalreise auf dem Himalaya, voll bepackt und so mit meinen Sachen und da wirklich nur ein, jetzt schnell noch Abendessen und dann ins Wochenende. Aber ich kenne das auch, also in meinem privaten Supermarkt, da ist man ja auch, das ist ja wie so ein verlängertes Wohnzimmer, wo man dann auch manchmal einfach so eine dreckige Hose, da hat man so nur Schlappen an und läuft dann halt da so durch. Man holt sich nur einen Dosenöffner, weil man sich denkt, fuck, ich will eine Dose öffnen und hab mich verknibbelt und brauch jetzt den ein. Ich hab noch so ein Handtuch um meine nassen Haare so hochgebunden und so, hab noch so Sachen aufgelegt. Ja genau, hab noch schon die Kältemaske.
Die Kältemaske schon so und lauf rum, weil es halt mein Supermarkt ist und sag, könnt ihr alle aus dem Weg gehen, ihr steht alle neben dem Weg. Ja, ja genau. Das ist mein Wohnzimmer basically. Von daher, ich kenn das auch. Und gerade meinen Supermarkt besuch ich häufig nach dem Fitnessstudio oder was auch immer, dann geht man da hin und dann will ich einfach nur was kaufen und raus, raus, raus, raus, raus. Und da haben mich auch schon oft Leute gesehen und die gesagt haben, alles an die hat gesagt, sprich mich nicht an, interagier nicht mit mir. Ich habe auch Kopfhörer drin und habe laut geschnauft, war die Aussage. Und ich verstehe das. Dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch, das ist ja komisch, wenn du dann plötzlich da gewesen wärst und wäre auch nicht so gegangen. Aber ich habe letztens was gemacht im Supermarkt, wo ich mir wirklich dachte, wow, vielleicht bin ich auch zu oft hier, weil du kennst es ja in seiner Wohnung, man hat ja manchmal so gewisse Griffpunkte in der Wohnung, irgendwie wenn du eine Treppe hast oder so, dann greifst du ins Geländer, greifst du blind ins Geländer und ziehst dich rum und läufst die Treppe hoch oder sowas oder wenn du ins Bad gehst, der Lichtschalter oder so, du hast einfach so Griffpunkte. Übrigens Schauspieler-Tipp, Schauspielerinnen-Tipp für mich. Wenn ihr in eigenen Wohnungen spielt oder so, man erkennt auch gut für nicht schlechte Schauspieler daran, dass sie das nicht machen. Weil in eigenen Wohnungen, man ist weird in eigenen Wohnungen, weil man die so gut kennt, dass du guckst nicht hin, wo der Lichtschalter ist. Du haust wild einfach rum, triffst ja dann auch mal nicht oder sowas. Und wie du schon sagst, man hat die perfekten Abkürzungen gefunden. Ja, absolut. Wie Mario Kart Strecke, 90.000 Mal gespielt. Du verlierst keine Geschwindigkeit durch. Und auch manchmal so kleine, du tappst mit der Hand irgendwo oben gegen die Decke oder in Regale oder irgendwie sowas, was dir wahrscheinlich gar nicht auffällt. Genau. Und letztens habe ich es im Supermarkt auch gemacht, dass ich mir in so einem Regal festgehalten habe und so rumgeschwungen habe, wo ich mir dachte, wow, das ist geil, wow, ich bin vielleicht ein bisschen zu oft hier, weil ich wirklich mich wohlgefühlt habe mit so einem hier bin ich, und dann dachte ich mir, ich muss jetzt wirklich, und dann dachte ich, ich komme zu Hause und da ist so eine Intervention, wo dann der Filialleiter sitzt und sagt, Pyrrhonthin, du bist es ist nicht, ich weiß, es fühlt sich wie zu Hause. Unser Slogan ist, literally, fühlen sie sich wie zu Hause. Ja, was machst ihr denn hier in meiner Wohnung? Aber es ist nicht ihr zu Hause. Naja, ich kaufe da halt gerne ein und also ... Genau, bitte schwing dich nicht, wie als wäre es dein Wohnzimmer durch unsere Regale. Okay, dann gehe ich halt zu einem anderen Supermarkt. Ich kann jederzeit zu einem anderen Supermarkt gehen, kein Problem. Okay, dann gehe ich halt einfach zu einem Edeka, kein Problem. Du kannst nicht. Du willst es psychisch nicht verkraften, zu einem anderen Supermarkt zu gehen. Klar, natürlich, dann gehe ich einfach woanders hin. Du hast ein kleines Loch reingebaut, reingesägt bei uns in Süßigkeitenregal, damit du schneller drüben bei den Drogeriemitteln bist. Ja, ist halt so entstanden, wenn man da oft, also... Es gibt einen Trittpfad. Es gibt einen kleinen, wie so einen Trittpfad, wo du immer lang gehst. Und da ist er bei Edeka und einfach haut sich überall den Kopf und so völlig überfordert. Du bist so oft in deinem Supermarkt, du hast auch eine Spurrille. Er kauft viel zu viel von irgendwas. Aber das habe ich mir auch gedacht. Wenn du wirklich jetzt mal für einen Tag lang deine Füsse unten so mit Farbe einstreichen würdest und du würdest den ganzen Tag die Fussschritte durch die Wohnung sozusagen aufzeich die Wohnung aufzeichnen, ich glaube, du würdest erst mal einen winzig kleinen Teil des Bodens überhaupt berühren, weil du, glaube ich, wirklich immer die exakt selben Schritte machst. Genau. Wenn du vom Bett zur Toilette gehst, glaube ich, du machst exakt die gleichen Schritte, wirklich jeden Tag. Das Spannende ist, als ich meine neue Wohnung eingezogen bin, habe ich den Boden, das war Holzboden, abschleifen lassen. Schön gemacht wieder. Und man sieht jetzt genau, welche Wege ich gehe. Weil Holzboden merkt das, ist empfindlich, der merkt genau, wo man lang geht. Und es gibt Orte, in denen ich noch nie war. Und es gibt Orte, an denen ich the whole time bin. Aber gehst du, manchmal denkst du dich, hier stand ich noch nie. Ich stand noch nie.
Und hier steht man so da.
Wow.
Wow, von hier sieht das Regal ja echt komisch aus.
Von hier sieht man den Mitbewohner, den ich offensichtlich habe.
Hi.
Hi, hallo.
Hallo.
Ist das ein Aquarium?
Ja, klar, wir haben ja ein Aquarium.
Ruder, das ist ein Fisch.
Ja, ja, klar, wir haben mehrere Fische. Hi. Hi, äh, hallo, ich bin Stefan. Ich bin Per. Okay, krass, wir haben anscheinend noch nie uns getroffen. Nee, du standst noch nie ... Ich stand hier noch nie. Offensichtlich nicht, aber immer höre ich dich, aber du standst noch nie da, dass du mich gesehen hast. Warum gehst du immer an Wänden lang, warum gehst du immer so komische ... Windschatten, ich möchte einfach nicht, dass ich Zeit verliere. Windschatten, nämlich nicht so viel, also gestern war Sturm aber auch nicht so doll, dass du jetzt irgendwie ... Ja, es ist vielleicht besser, dass wir nicht so viel zusammen miteinander zu tun haben, oder Peer. Warum sagst du meinen Namen, weil es wäre weird. Ich mag kurze Namen nicht so gern. Warum sagst du nicht Peer? Ich mag kurze Namen nicht so gern. Ich war mal in einem Escape Room und mir ist nicht ein Tier mit drei Buchstaben eingefallen. Und seitdem haben alle mit drei Buchstaben bei mir irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ist einfach so ein Ding. Hey Team, versuchts doch mal mit Uhu. Ja, okay, danke für den Tipp, danke für den Wagen-Tipp. Geht's noch vager. Dass man als Familie versagt hat, wenn die Tipps sind, drückt doch mal die Blautaste.
Das bin ich froh, dass das nicht kam.
Versucht's doch mal mit 8853.
Ah, danke für den Tipp.
Danke für diesen Hinweis.
Das hat so Spaß gemacht.
Am Ende hat er gesagt, versuch's doch mal mit 8853.
Wir haben es eingegeben und der Tresor ging auf.
Wow.
Das war so cool.
Das war so ein guter Tipp.
Es war so cool. Wir haben genau 60 Minuten gebraucht. Ja. Wir haben jetzt 52 gebraucht. Und damit waren wir besser als die Familie davor und unsere Feindes-Rivalen-Familie. Ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Und ich bin richtig happy drüber. Ich dachte gerade wie ... Du sahst nicht happy aus im Supermarkt. Du sahst ... sehr angespannt aus, sehr gehetzt. Supermärkte mag ich nicht gern. Ich schwitze auch immer in Supermärkten. Es gibt so ein paar Orte, wo es mir nicht so mega gut geht. Supermarkt gehört definitiv dazu, ich will einfach raus wieder. Echt? Aber wenn du sagst, du hast da so Selbst-Checkout-Sachen bei dir, normalerweise ist das ja mega geil. Ich liebe dieses Selbst, da gibt es im Kölner Hauptbahnhof auch so einen Laden, wo es fast nur die gibt, und da bin ich manchmal sonntags, weil ich vergesse, welcher Wochentag ist, und da muss ich da manchmal einkaufen, und ich liebe das, dieses selber abscannen, und du kannst ja auch ein bisschen klauen. Und dann kannst du halt so ... Kann man nicht, traue ich mich nicht. Würde ich nie. Da steht immer eine Mitarbeiterin, ein Mitarbeiter, und man muss dann den Bon auch manchmal ...
Ja, aber den Mitarbeiter, das kann man ja machen.
So, Augenzwählen.
Ich hab tatsächlich ... Manchmal hab ich so Kopfkino,
lieg im Bett und überleg mir, wie würde ich leben,
wenn ich wirklich nur noch ganz wenig Geld hätte,
wenn ich nur noch so zehn Euro im Monat zur Verfügung hätte.
Ich glaub, klauen wär sofort das Erste, was ich machen würde.
Und ich hab auch überlegt, ich würde vor allem ganz viele Pfanddosen klauen, um die dann wieder zum Pfand zu machen, um mir damit andere Sachen, die schwerer zu klauen sind, zu kaufen. Also ich habe mir überlegt, dass ich dann vielleicht mit den zehn Euro mir so eine Art, also jetzt nur eine Idee, mir so eine Art Kinderwagen kaufe, so einen gebrauchten Kinderwagen für 10 Euro. Das wäre dein Erster. Wenn du nichts mehr hättest, wäre das deine Investition? Und dann würde ich da hinfahren und würde da ganz viele Dosen reinlegen in den Kinderwagen und dann so eine Decke drüber mit so einem kleinen Teddybär. Du hast den her. Ja gut, auf jeden Fall kriegst du für 10 Euro so eine Kombo. Da muss ich keinen Kredit aufnehmen. Da muss ich einen Kredit aufnehmen für zehn Euro. Kannst du nicht, wenn du zehn Euro hast, kannst du keinen Kredit aufnehmen. Naja, dann gucke ich halt das, naja, du kannst ja aus Gräsern kannst du dann so einen kleinen Tonnen. Aber du kannst Babyskruppe klauen, die können sich sehr schlecht werden. Das stimmt. Und wenn sie weinen, weiss man nicht, ja genau, klau die einfach. Das ist auch nicht schlecht. Okay, dann hast du das. Und dann habe ich den Kinderwagen und dann tue ich da die ganzen Dosen rein und so und dann kau ich die.
Super.
Und dann weiss ich noch nicht, ob ich die Dosen austrinke oder nicht. Das habe ich noch nicht entschieden.
Ey, wenn du nur zehn Euro hättest, solltest du definitiv was austrinken.
Ja gut, aber ich weiss nicht, ob das so gesund ist, wenn ich dann jeden Tag acht Liter Cola Light trinken muss.
Kauf dir Wasserdosen.
Ja, okay. Ja, dann kaufe ich mir einfach die Wasserdosen. Danke, Stefan.
Man merkt, du warst schon lange nicht mehr im normalen Einkauf. Aber dann kann ich die Dosen wegbringen und krieg das, das wäre meine Idee.
Kannst du die wegbringen, kriegst wie viel Cent pro Dose?
25 Cent pro Dose, das ist gar nicht so schlecht. Das heisst, ich dachte mir, keine Ahnung, wenn du jeden Tag so 30 Dosen oder so, 40 Dosen, sind es dann 10 Euro, ist nicht schlecht, dann hast du weitere zehn Euro pro Tag.
Und damit kannst du dir dann die Sachen kaufen, die du schlecht kalauen kannst. Ja super, lass uns mal so ein Selbstexperiment machen. Das wäre auch mal cool, wenn du bei TikTok einfach oder bei Insta machst so Selbstexperimente. Ja, oder halt, ich dachte mir so eine Dose an so einer Stange oder so, dass ich die Dose reintue in den Automaten und dann wieder rausziehe und wieder rein. ichiss nicht ob das klappt ob die wirklich mit sicher klappt nicht ob die wirklich den strich code scan und irgendwo eine datenbank liegt von allen dosen die bereits wieder eingegeben wurden oder ob also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass das so elaboriert ist ehrlich gesagt aber das ding ist ja an fand automaten hast ja immer eine schlange und ich glaube ja leute würden sauer werden wenn sie dich da mit so einer Angelschnur sehen. Und dann machst du eine Dose da rein, holst dich wieder raus. Wie viele Dosen musst du rausziehen wieder, bis jemand hinterher sagt, so, danke. Vor allem, ich glaube, ich wäre so devot, dass ich, wenn ich hinter dem stehen würde, einfach geduldig warten würde. Ja, ich würde auch warten. Geduldig warten würde mit meiner Ikea-Tasche. Ich würde mir überlegen, einfach bis der seine 600 Euro gemacht hat mit der Dose.
Eben nicht. Ich würde sagen, ich lasse den, also ich würde selber überlegen, wie viel würde ich denn selber, 20.
20 Euro pro Tag.
Alles andere fände ich dreist. Ne, ne, 20 mal rein und raus.
Ach so, 20.
Das finde ich eine gute Zahl.
Okay, das sind 5 Euro.
Dann würde ich mitzählen dahinter, Devote dahinter stehen, mitzählen und nach 20 würde ich vielleicht sagen,
Entschuldigung, kann ich mich kurz dazwischen...
Kann ich mal kurz vielleicht...
Komm mir mal wieder da.
Komm mir mal wieder da. Komm mir mal wieder, so verabrehe ich du mir Öffentlichkeit. Aber das ist das Gute an meinem Supermarkt, zwei Leergutautomaten, zwei Leergutautomaten, wo der eine immer defekt ist und der andere eine 90 Kilometer Schlange davor hat, dreckiger Supermarkt.
Ich will das echt mal ausprobieren, aber ich weiss nicht, meine Angst ist, dass wenn man dann so die Dose reintut und dann wieder rausnimmt
und wenn der Automat wirkt, die Dose war schon mal,
dass dann so eine Handschelle kommt
und dich sofort verhaftet
und du auch nicht mehr fliehen kannst.
Und dann steckst du da. Und dann kommt so eine andere Hand
mit so einem Schlagschlock.
Und haut der einfach so auf den Kopf.
Und dann habe ich Angst, dass ich Hausverbot kriege
und dann wüsste ich nicht, was ich tun soll. Warum sind die Automaten
so gemein?
Das sind Tasers.
Das ist ein Hausrecht, wir dürfen ja machen, was wir wollen.
R2-D2. Ja, ist das so?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Darf man in Häusern machen, was man will?
Ja, du hast ein eigenes Rechtssystem, nur in deinem Haus.
Du darfst sagen, auf Diebstahl stehen drei Schläge.
Dann darfst du das durchsetzen, Hausrecht. Hausrecht ist alles.
Das Gesetzbuch für Hausrecht ist sehr dünn. Wollen wir ein Hausrechtsmuseum aufmachen? Du hast nur so eine Seite Hausrecht. In seinem eigenen Haus darf jeder machen, was er will. Ende. Ende Gelände. Copyright. Vielen, vielen Dank nochmal an Christian Solmecke, gewidmet Rechtsanwalt und Partner bei WBS Legal in Köln. Ui, ui, da guckt aber jemand häufig die Videos,
dass er das schon verinnerlicht hat.
Aber lass uns das Deutsche Hausrechtsmuseum gründen, okay?
Oh, das finde ich auch gut.
Klingt ähnlich sperrig, ähnlich boring as fuck,
aber ich würde es gerne gründen, weil vielleicht liegt da Potenzial.
Was sieht man da? Verschiedene Häuser und was man alles darf?
Also die, vielleicht so die ulkigsten Hausrechte,
so dass man sagt, ja, also kein T-Shirt, kein Service, solche Geschichten.
Mhm. So was. T-Shirt, kein Service. Ja, klingt nicht so schmissig, aber gut, das ist ja vielleicht ein Negativbeispiel im Hausrechtmuseum. Nee, ich finde, man lädt einfach Leute ein in unser wildes kleines Haus, wo ein ganz komisches Rechtssystem besteht. Wo die Leute nicht wissen, was das Recht ist. Todesstrafe, warum existiert. Oh nein, ups, schade,
jetzt kommt unser Piranha-Becken.
Macht das auf jeden Fall.
Wir hoffen, euch begrüssen zu dürfen demnächst in vielen, vielen tollen Städten,
wo ihr eine tolle Zeit verbringt, um endlich wieder neue
Gesprächsthemen zu haben. Ansonsten lassen wir euch
jetzt allein. Halt die Klappe, ansonsten haltet eure Klappe,
wir lassen euch wieder allein in euren dysfunktionalen
Beziehungen. Wir sehen euch
nächste Woche wieder, macht's gut, bis dahin, tschüss, wir geben...